Victor timewolf okay you're back do you
have audio now
I do sorry there we go as soon as you
pulled me in I got a call and it's so
weird
um regarding the topic I don't have
anything but uh except if you we count
the right way you don't have like your
wife's boyfriend doesn't have a solution
all this with finances I'm a single and
I'm happy about it unless without saying
left and right hand all right
um so what do you got for me tonight you
got a question here yeah uh uh I read
your book back in May April and after
that I put it down breathe out took a
pen and paper and wrote down the red
flags of my previous relationship and I
noticed that all of this like seven out
of like 10 let's say uh red flags have
with my mother uh so the question is uh
does Man actually like
chooses a woman on a red flags as well
like that's a good question so there's
been some speculation
um I can't cite the exact Source because
I went through this a long time ago but
there's been some speculation that a lot
of the times guys will select women
they'll invite women in their lives and
relationships or marriages that are very
similar to their mother
right and one of the things that was
also speculated
um and again this is I don't know how
accurate this is but there's discussion
along the lines of
um
Whenever there was conflict in your
household growing up between your
parents you would essentially try to
resolve that in your own adult life
right like let's say your dad I don't
know let's just make something like your
dad was sloppy and incompetent and your
mom was a a [ __ ] Relentless [ __ ] you
know sort of thing it's like you try to
be better than your dad was more
competent more useful and then you try
to deal with a woman that is
um too [ __ ] and you try to like you
know take her down to a place where
she's happy you know it's like the
Captain Save A Hoe sort of thing or
you're trying to spend your life making
an unhappy person happy sort of thing
like apparently this is fairly common
um I don't know
you know what the stats are there's
going to be somebody in the comment it's
going to be like yep just Google this
study sort of thing and you know maybe
they'll drop it there for us later on
but I think there's
I think you're on to something with that
and you got to be aware of it
um I was talking to people about the red
flag chapter earlier today in a private
Zoom call that I had because
um I was doing my zoom q a with the
business guys in the School of
Entrepreneurship and one of the things
that came up was
um
identifying what not to do and I think
in life with women with business and a
lot of these things if you get really
really clear on what you don't want to
involve in your life like if you don't
want a hard business then try to stay
away from moving physical products right
try to stay away from businesses that
are going to be location dependent to a
certain geographic region where you need
like a brick and mortar with a neon sign
that flashes and turns on when you open
up the door those sorts of things same
sort of things with women right like if
you know that there's patterns of of
women that are difficult that are going
to add complexity to your life then
don't get into long-term relationships
with them don't knock them up don't put
babies in them don't marry them date
them if you want maybe friends with
benefits but
that's it you know figure them out and
then move on to the next one right like
as soon as you identify that she's got a
bunch of red flags and
um you know she's good friends with MAO
and she was in the last uh parade with
you know the red flag bearer sort of
thing just move on from it yeah my
thinking was it's gone uh comfortability
like you find a woman what you're
comfortable with as your mother and
basically that's the reason why you like
kind of with her but like well look I
mean if you're used to a certain type of
woman at the head of the household
um that you had some I mean you
obviously had a lot of exposure to you
know as a kid then you're probably less
likely to see the red flag right like
one of the red flags number three is
avoid the unhappy and unlucky let's say
you grew up in a household where your
mom was always complaining we don't have
this and why does Becky have that and
you're you're cheap and that is sort of
like just constantly complaining for 20
years of your life if you meet a woman
that's unhappy and unlucky chances are
because you're used to it maybe you
didn't see it that you just think well
that's normal you know a woman should be
unhappy and I'm unlucky and she should
always complain about [ __ ] and I should
be there to listen to it and be the
shoulder crying so
you know I can see those dots certainly
connecting but I'm not going to analyze
that I'm just going to say look just
avoid women that are unhappy and unlucky
simple as that
okay in your practice I mean when he was
doing it was interviews with other guys
you didn't know this is the same thing
like happening
um I never really you'll never see me
say anything like so what was your
relationship like you know with your
mother mother or anything like that I'm
not a therapist I'm not qualified to
deal with that [ __ ] and to be honest
with you I don't really [ __ ] care to
be like
I find a lot of therapists aren't that
useful you know to be perfectly honest
and they probably don't do that much
good and they have this sort of
subscription model where they want you
to keep coming back to go through
session and session session that's how
they make their money so
you know My Philosophy is simply
identify the problem and stay away from
it you know if she's a rapid feminist
don't marry her if she's uh you know
shitty with money and has lots of debt
that's not your problem she's violent
she throws [ __ ] at people you know
knives glass jars [ __ ] that I don't want
anything to do with that right I don't
really care what her relationship is
with her mother or why she behaves that
way I just know that it's a problem and
I don't want her problem in my life
don't make your problems my problems
right that's why I don't go to the to
the hole well tell me about your
childhood and what your relationship was
with your mother and father I don't do
that [ __ ] because I think that's a waste
of time
okay make sense cool yeah cool thank you
very much all right Vic see you buddy
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out